hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2019 science fiction and thriller movie
called butt boy
this movie has a very unique concept and
storyline make sure to watch it till the
end to find out
the story begins with chip gutchal an
i.t staff in a small corporate company
who seems unhappy with his current job
and unhappy with his life
while having dinner with his family chip
tells his wife that he is going to get
his very first prostate exam tomorrow
it seems like their current relationship
is not that good his wife then continues
talking to her friend on the phone
leaving and ignoring chip alone with
their baby
moving on to the next day chip meets his
doctor
surprisingly he begins to feel and
discover a new kind of sensation while
the doctor is examining him
since then chip's weird habit to stick
things up his butt which he finds
unexpectedly pleasurable begins the
first thing to disappear is a bar of
soap which he finds while having a bath
the next day even a tv remote control
becomes a victim of chip's bizarre
behavior his wife tries to find the
missing remote control but chip pretends
like he doesn't know anything
worse thing happens when he is left
alone in the house where the poor rocky
his own dog becomes the next victim and
disappears
chip and his wife go to the local park
to find the missing rocky but as soon as
he sees a woman carrying her baby while
sitting in the park suddenly chip asks
his wife to go home and let him do the
finding
can you guys guess what he is going to
do
from chip's facial expression we can see
that he is thinking about shoving humans
up to his butt and later on he carries
out his thinking
a few moments later several cops come to
chip's house and question him regarding
the missing child at the park
chip plays dumb and tells the cops that
he didn't see anything strange at the
park
ship even helps the local community to
find the missing child before
self-disgust almost overwhelms him
at some point he also attempts to commit
suicide but the rope cuts off
the scene jumps forward nine years when
a local detective named russell fox
attends an alcoholics anonymous or a
group
this group is a recovery support for
alcoholic people
there they gather and share about their
problems as a newcomer he is linked up
with a sponsor who turns out to be chip
himself
chip and russell then go for dinner
where russell shares that he is not
married and has no kids
on the other hand chip also admits that
his marriage is not in a good condition
even after several years have passed
ship seems still cannot escape from his
bad habit
while playing monopoly with his family
he is triggered by a blue plastic cone
and can't get it out of his mind
at night after some hesitation chip
finally takes that piece and puts it
into his butt on the other side we
discover that russell became an
alcoholic for a reason he stalks a girl
with her husband who seems to be his
ex-wife he even tries to call the girl
but receives no answer
chip's addiction is now out of control
as he keeps inserting random stuff even
a big one into his butt and he seems to
enjoy it very much
he inserts almost everything that is
available in his house without having
his wife know what he has been doing
at work chip's boss wants to conduct to
take your child to work day where all
the employees of the company bring their
kids to work and play together with them
the day comes and chip's boss asks all
the children to play hide and seek but
chip just keeps working as usual
after doing so well in his previous
missions russell is assigned to
investigate a missing kid in the
business district an hour ago guess what
yeah it's in the company where chip
works
russell arrives at the office and learns
that every camera in that office has
been wiped he starts interviewing the
employees one by one until the last one
which turns out to be chip
russell suspects chip to be the culprit
as he is the only i t guy who has the
capability to edit and remove a
surveillance camera status
later we discover that it was really
chip who kidnapped the child by using
his superpower butt and kept the cctv
recording but he refuses to answer
russell and walks away from the
interview
russell then becomes more suspicious
towards chip as he finds a clue while
inspecting his table
after work chip's wife discovers that
her husband has been joining an aaa
group all this time claiming that chip
has been lying all the time
feeling stressed chip decides to go out
at night but it turns out that he goes
to adopt a new pet at the same time
russell is tailing chip to find out
about his suspicion he hides inside his
car so the chip won't spot him because
of this he lost sight of chip he then
roams around a fine chip and eventually
he finds the cage where chip keeps the
adopted pet but strangely there's
nothing there
there he also finds something similar to
the clue he finds in chip's office desk
the next day russell explains to his
superior that chip is the kidnapper by
cramming objects especially the missing
child up his butt but his boss doesn't
buy the theory leaving the detective
with no choice but to go rogue
after being absent for a week chip
finally comes back to the aaa sharing
session
after the sharing session chip invites
russell to come over to have dinner at
his house the detective tells chip's
wife that he is pretty close to finding
the kidnapper which makes chip panic he
tries to change the topic by asking
russell whether he has a girlfriend or
not before the detective leaves he
suddenly asks chip to borrow the
bathroom chip seems panicked because he
kept the cctv recording in the bathroom
out of nowhere he starts banging the
door forcing russell to get out
immediately but fortunately russell
manages to discover the disc before the
door is broken
while driving home russell realizes that
he has been tailed by chip
he stops and both of them start fighting
eventually the detective wins the fight
but suddenly chip puts down his pants
and starts producing a huge air vortex
from his butt pulling russell's car
but somehow russell manages to start the
car and drives away
he immediately goes to his former boss's
office to prove his statements before
but sadly his boss tells him to get lost
at some point russell is finally brave
enough to visit the girl that was shown
in the previous scene proving that she
is indeed his ex-wife that is currently
married to a new guy
later he sneaks into his former office
there we also discover that the missing
baby at the very first scene of the
movie is russell's that is why he seems
to be so desperate and hopeless
throughout the movie
long story short to celebrate chip's
son's birthday chip invites his family
and friends to play laser battlefield
unexpectedly russell also joins the
battlefield but with a real gun aiming
is a a sponsor who turns out to be his
baby's kidnapper he manages to shoot
chip in the leg
feeling cornered ship unleashes his
ultimate weapon which is the same huge
air vortex from his butt causing russell
to pass out russell wakes up in a very
strange and smelly environment
there he meets andrew the missing child
who was kidnapped at chip's office he
states that they are currently at chip's
digestive system to be exact rectum
suddenly a huge amount of gas is
released and it turns out that it is a
fart after that russell and andrew
continue exploring chip's digestive
system they managed to find rocky the
missing dog and russell's missing baby
who has grown into a young boy they also
discover all the stuff that chip shoved
up his butt
one month later after getting shot
chip's butt is being examined by a
doctor before being released to ensure
no internal bleeding occurs
because of that russell manages to find
a way out and starts planning a strategy
chip also gets appreciated by his aa's
mates and even gets a promotion at his
office because of chip's bravery to
escape from a life or death situation
later russell's strategy seems to be
working as chip starts to discharge the
soap tv remote control and even his dog
from his butt to cure his stomachache
chip drinks a bottle of stomach elixir
but this liquid drops into andrew's face
leaves burn marks and a few moments
later he dies
the next day chip is invited by mayor
cage to celebrate his braveness while
giving his speech at the podium he feels
something is wrong with his stomach
turns out that russell has been pouring
liquid that triggers chip's digestive
system to produce a huge amount of gas
after that he lights up his lighter
causing chip to explode and die
immediately in the middle of chaos
russell and his son managed to survive
and wrestle hands over the cctv
according to his shocked boss
at the end of the movie russell brings
his long-awaited son to the hospital
where the kid finally manages to meet
his mom again
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching